well as thousands of people in ukraine
flee the country there are some going
the other way heading into the conflict
zone
those wanting to take up arms others
providing aid and some just desperate to
be with or to bring back their families
and in omni
is one of those he's a 28 year old from
manchester who was back in ukraine uh
trying to do just that get his wife and
son out he had quite a journey in he
joins me now from nicopal in ukraine in
uh great to talk to you
we all remember waking up on thursday
morning to news of the invasion what did
you
think when you heard what had happened
overnight
my world fell apart at that time i was
woken
uh very early by my wife and
she mentioned that they had started
bombing and that was
five coffees in my system i was up i was
frantic the news was on i turned on sky
news straight away and
i was shook to the core um and
my instant reaction was to get a car and
to drive as soon as i could um but
luckily i calmed down a bit my friends
and family talked me out of going there
straight away even tried to talk me out
of going there full stop but my family's
here and love transcends war
or danger in my opinion
so how was your journey across
long tiring uh full of love and support
both from the online community and the
community on the border and in ukraine
so i was very lucky actually i had no
plan as soon as i got to the border what
to do from then on so i was more than
willing
to to trek the 80 kilometers to lev
but i didn't have to i only had to do a
fraction of that about five or six
kilometers and then i met um some people
who were ferrying children and women to
the border and soldiers inland so i
helped them on a few runs
and then
with a bit more luck and a bit more
frustration throughout the day i made it
onto the train
and then eventually made it here
yesterday afternoon
what was that reunion like
emotional i got off the bus and i walked
to the apartment uh door and
my son and my wife were there and my son
held his arms open to me i hugged him
and i wept into my wife's shoulder and
it was the best feeling ever it was well
worth the stress and the risk
glad to hear it
so what's the plan now how long are you
going to stay are you just going to try
and turn around and bring them both
straight back out
we need to uh we need to analyze the
situation and work at what's the best
thing that we can do
and i would obviously like to get them
out um but we have to discuss this today
and work out a solution to
our biggest life problem which is um do
we stay do we go how do we go is it safe
to go because at the minute we can see
that russia are in the south in kirsan
which is not too far from nicopol
um and by all means they're planned to
split the country uh in half from kiev
to
odessa um it's uh it's right in our path
so we need to make a decision uh very
quickly
if you wanted to to leave what is the
visa situation would they your wife and
child be able to come into the uk easily
yes they still have an existing tourist
visa so they can come over on that but
the uk government has also put in an
express spouse visa for uh families of
british citizens in ukraine so
that's a very welcome uh change to uh
what the uk are doing to help people in
ukraine
but of course it is a difficult decision
because for your wife and child and for
you as well you will have
other people that you love and care
about in ukraine you've got friends
there you've got colleagues there
how hard is it to to think about leaving
them behind
extremely hard my father's here my
father's lived here longer than i have
and i spoke to him yesterday and he gave
me some information about what he was
planning on doing and um it's it's going
to be hard um
i i'm not leaving i'm um i'm staying
here to help with any way i can uh
whether it's food aid
building roadblocks um or making things
or carrying certain uh
items to to defend uh ukraine so
um i'm in the in this thought that
ukrainian citizens who are over 18 and
male can't leave so why should i have
been here for so long my friends and
family are still here um i need to do as
much as i can to help the situation
would you consider fighting
i would yes
that must be quite a big decision
people here have no choice so they don't
have a decision to make it's already
made for them it's inevitable so
um me being a volunteer i'm i'm here to
help other people so
if i need to be
if i need to bear arms then i'm 100
willing to uh in order to defend ukraine
it's really great to talk to you ian and
i hope you'll you'll keep us informed
here on sky you know you've got a big
twitter following a lot of people
following your journey
across into ukraine whatever you decide
to do and i hope your your family stays
safe thanks so much